we were trying to say citizens of the
reject nation in Spanish I said it
exactly right I'm pretty sure she nailed
it
yep guys we are back we are here to do
wreck dose
I am so excited we should tamper our
expectations only because it's a sequel
and that first one was like a
masterpiece dope amazing there's very
few movies where we react to them here
and then I often still think about it
it's been like a week or something since
we watched it think about it like every
single day I really love that experience
it's so freaking good so terrifying so
Tara should they leave a like yes and
they should also ring the bell
ring the bell
as always fully stretch and watch long
story sync up with your own copy of
wreck 2 available for a super sexy
Rejects at our patreon page thank you
all who have joined our patreon so far
for being so punched because of all the
crap we've been covering we're gonna
cover uh you know several exclusive
craps over there with reaction
highlights and watch alongs included
Tara is in here with this the sentence
in Spanish
is that the only thing you know see
thank you
[Music]
this is already a little scary
oh
yeah
oh this is cool we're gonna be getting
it from the like SWAT team's perspective
uh multiple angles now
um
damn this one feels like it's going to
be way more violent
oh man
yeah is that like a grenade launcher I
think it's those things you break
indoors with oh yeah all right or maybe
I don't know
foreign
[Music]
oh man memories
oh [__] she got loose
look how high definition this one is
keeping One camera going or two also I'd
be like I'm just gonna wear it for
safety there's a lot of blood around who
do you think we'll see Angela as a
zombie that'd be cool yes
first time you really get the sense of
all four of the floors or however big
this building is yeah it was just one
big shot
how do you think
that's called a battering ram okay all
right
oh they're in the uh yeah well good luck
I love how immediate this is
answers
oh yeah the little boy oh
the gorilla
I just love living in this world yeah
what happened last time
boy
oh boy where'd he go
es
of course you're not alone
I mean even if they're not survivors
you're going to want to take care of the
problem though yeah man don't you hear
that growling that guy should really
explain what they're dealing with what
the heck is going on so that way they
know to kill when they start running
after them
my entire
is
it the same it seems to be you got a
whole hallway to go down buddy a little
girl oh right like watching TV or
something or the dad the remember
yes and he was sick in bed
[Music]
once he turns it off yeah it's probably
calms the zombies
good
oh my God come on kill it
shoot it oh my God
whoa
oh my God oh my God
he went alone
oh my god did he transform already
[Music]
all right shoot him oh my God
so it is
[Music]
oh my God oh damn they just answer that
question y'all better go get a Bible
what oh
yeah okay all right oh neat all right
why didn't the previous medical guy do
that [__] before
La Nina
they get all this information in two
hours
so it is a demonic possession that forms
into a chemical so you can still treat
it potentially
this makes a lot more sense how we knew
all this is
well then grab a Bible and start praying
my God it's interesting they're trying
they're doing like a marriage of both a
virus infection and a demonic possession
right I don't know if I've quite seen
that
okay nope yeah those masks would come in
handy right now guys
this one plays a little bit like a
survival horror game like Resident Evil
yeah
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
yo priest you're gonna die it's
frustrating as a priest is you really
need him alive
that's one solution
[Music]
oh holy crap oh no old
or is this a corpse yeah
oh
is that the apartment oh that's the
person originally
like how the sequel is like answers
[Laughter]
that's what I was worried about
don't look the prescription bit don't
let the priests get bitty you need the
priest somebody grab a Bible of anything
from that room oh my God
oh my God that's terrifying what the
hell
guys use your brain shoot it whoa
oh
look priest I'm all down for being
ominous and all that [__] you really
gotta like prepare everybody
this is like brand new to them really
like clue them in on what's going on
oh God are those like little cages where
they kept them or were these just air
ducts I need to know
oh
okay
sample blood take it
down
what's down there I'm so scared
no worries I was just gonna pop out put
that thing in a safe place in your
pocket buddy whoa what's happening what
is that thing
's gonna come through what's going on no
thank you shoot come on shoot it
yeah
oh there's several of them oh yeah that
is where they were all kept is where
they were all kept at not just an air
duct after all hello
check it how what what will you check
how are you gonna do it did you bring in
stuff for a whole like what's going on
did you bring gloves sir okay never mind
it's out in the open I forget that it's
religious
someone
so can I burn Amigos
no oh my god really guys that is so
frustrating
was that just a regular guy a regular
guy
he's got antibiotics
Poor Dad he did a good job breaking
through the barrier and sneaking up all
those stairs why was he all the way
upstairs
loran
Holy balls okay it's cascading on you
yeah I use it come on
yo that guy come on
uh the firefighter guy
how how are they getting out of this
no oh God
oh God
this one section he's so frustrating
okay
yes it is
[Applause]
oh you're out of ammo do you have a
knife do you have a knife stab him in
the head
oh my God oh my God he's surrounded okay
whoa oh that old guy yeah yeah guy cared
about his looks
like is he telling him to do what I
think he's telling him to do
oh he was not telling him to do that no
foreign
Pack's a different kind of visceral
punch
incorrect okay it's cascading like
cacophony of course
it's interesting how this one took a
much more
cinematic approach yeah it's more like
genre heavy
style but it's it's fun though I'm
having fun
[Applause]
okay
oh gosh she's feisty
somebody find a knife man the weapon
that never dies
oh neat
what the heck oh my goodness
full-on exorcism
what the [__]
[Music]
oh god oh nope you got blood in your
mouth
foreign
[Music]
are we going to the kids the camera
[Laughter]
well the flyer just catch on fire does
it just gonna oh god oh yeah why would
it fly
thank you
and that's the last time we see the kids
oh yeah they follow him because he got
in and then they came in after
foreign
that is the most realistic found footage
run I've ever seen
it
oh God
I want these kids to die
I don't like them at all the girls are
right
she's all right
dumbass oh God
what what are you doing God what a dumb
kid
all right
a firefighter saving your life
okay so they do like I question can they
just jump out the window but they would
shoot them
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my God what the
oh man
[Applause]
whoa
I mean she flew a little bit
so maybe he was infected when they shot
him yes because he had blood on him so
he came the second okay this all
happened
uh
stay away from the window bro okay what
[Applause]
yo stop shooting they're still shooting
would this be the protocol where they
would just keep shooting like that
[Applause]
okay so they're softening the blow a
little bit so yeah I didn't quite turn
yet right
oh boy yep there he goes
it's a nice little Easter egg to what
happened before
GPS
is it like a demon lure thing is that oh
it's the little girl the little girl who
bit her mom right the one who just died
I wonder who just got shot when we were
with the cops
oh the priest
holy crap that's terrifying I don't
wanna know that's terrifying foreign
what is that it's the cop right
flash of light on the face come on now
whoa
oh man this firefighter goes these kids
are screwed
[Applause]
that's the wrong one
oh my God
okay now shoot that one
okay
this poor girl has just been thrusted to
all these terrible things
God
this is also stressful
foreign
like a billion other zombies
yes
let him turn and use him exactly yeah
both of them okay so he's gonna turn and
now eat try to eat his sister she's
gonna turn
thank God it was this kid
who's that
oh my gosh she's back she lives what
damn what how Generations
living room
how'd she live
because I think
oh right because she was the only one
left with that weird Zombie thing in
there right yeah it's been but then
maybe somebody spent a lot of time
passed before these guys got in here
though
[Music]
okay
that's right that's right yeah
oh boy
because they were full on Supernatural
wow
no I can't oh God oh my stomachs are
hurt stash
upstairs
you gotta check again buddy
so you have to do it in night vision
I still don't know how she's living yeah
like who pulled her underneath the bed
but she was the last one it was her hoop
holder yeah somehow she like got free of
it I don't know she was playing with a
necklace does she have a necklace that
had a cross she had a first one she did
yeah
oh see y'all need to be grabbing crosses
off the wall
telling you right now you might be right
about that I think I think
[Music]
this poor girl
died
turn off the lights
in darkness she may come
on
don't worry the hell they're on the
Highway to Hell
unless you have the night vision you can
only access this door in the Darkness
unless Angela's actually dead and she's
being possessed or some [__] you know to
lure them oh
God everything is different straight up
like a video game level
God so much of this is felt that way
weird
okay
good morning
what oh my God
you don't have an extra light on you you
have a flashlight come on SWAT guy
what what is this she's back for more
[Applause]
I would turn the light on I would turn
the light on
but not before we take her blood
exactly do you think you're gonna just
get her blood exactly like how is this
gonna work don't you think the guy with
the camera should be the one should be
the one that gets the blood like give
the priest a camera or vice versa
okay
no she's right there oh my God no thank
you
oh is he gonna direct her to get them
I'm sure if you turn on the light you
can
like she would just like disappear would
she well no she would still be stuck in
that world right like it would be
no thanks
oh well
you're in Fort now good thing she's
coming for you because you need to get
her blood sir
oh my God this is just unbearable
get your blood get the blood somehow
[Music]
oh
yeah
there's plenty of her blood like why is
it when they die he can't get it it's
what what is happening
then get the blood buddy
oh yeah
all right get it girl
did you find her body in the dark
right and get the blood that's what I'm
saying like turn the lights off get her
blood real quick
you eventually reach a limit and she's
reached it
oh
all right girl whoa okay she's done
she possessed I'm she wants it to spread
yeah
how did you oh God oh God
oh my only way it made sense only way it
made sense
foreign she could just do a voice thing
can't she
exactly yeah
oh my goodness it's painful that's
painful
are you dead
[Music]
clever
look right at the camera yep
[Music]
just having just having some fun oh damn
oh we're really gonna see this oh oh
okay
oh God no I hate it oh my God
[Applause]
oh my God oh my God oh my God I hate it
so that's how you transfer oh my God
Oh see it wasn't that long since the
they came in
review
oh my God
oh my God whoa what a journey
that was so weird the last shot I can't
oh that was really gross that's really
gross God help us I mean there were so
many crosses in that entire everyone was
Catholic or very religious in every
house and no one thought to be like let
me just carry this bad boy around yeah
come on now well dang I got a lot of
thoughts on that did you like it I did
like it I mean yeah not as much as the
first one the the thing that I knew it
wouldn't be a little slight adjustment
here there you go a thing that I knew
initially from the beginning
um was that I was maybe not going to
like it as much of having the four
representations of the four body cameras
yeah because I really liked that the
first one only stuck to one POV yeah um
because it it's harder to make that and
but yes I I did I did like it yeah it
was a bit of an adjustment at first yes
because instantaneously like when you
see the quality of what it is you're
like wow this is really clean and crisp
sharp you know whereas the other one had
a much more gritty instant effect you
know like yeah like yeah sure it's a
news team but they're like doing some
like shitty report at like three in the
morning yeah yeah they're not getting
like the best equipment and all that
stuff because
I think though the thing with found
footage is that whenever you do a sequel
it's instantaneously going to feel
gimmicky yeah like of course it's gonna
be found footage again you know it
instantaneously feel gimmicky at that
point so it's kind of an unavoidable
trap so I think yeah that they had to do
what they're doing yeah so I think the
fact that they took it a different
direction with how to capture it and how
to go about doing the story while still
continuing the exact same story
I thought was I really appreciated it it
was a bit of an adjustment but as it
kept playing out and I got accustomed to
it I I started to really like like oh
yeah this one the first one feels like
super real yeah and there's a good build
up and this one's like immediate
um just the horror right away and it's a
bunch of answers coming left and right
an evolution of Supernatural and uh like
different styles you know yeah and uh so
while I yeah I mean the first one is
just kind of this contain Masterpiece
and then this one though if you're gonna
do a sequel if they just did it the
exact same way it'd be like
yes yeah I'm just trying to do so I like
that this one is different you know it
played with it it felt like it was like
oh yeah now they have a budget because
they made the first one and people were
probably like yeah of course well here's
more money like more zombies more
special effects and you can have more
points of view get into like more rooms
like it they they did a lot of like
tricks I think for our brain in the
first one that played with like a lower
budget and this one as I'm watching it
like it was like they could just have
more people more things involved and
obviously a lot more zombies maybe maybe
in the in the first one they might be
like you're wrong we could have had as
many zombies as we wanted and we made it
just the way they wanted which was great
but in this one I just felt like oh they
can play around with like more yeah and
then they did that the entire time it
was a lot they had a lot more fun you
could tell that they were having fun
like right down at the very and she
looks like right at the camera at the
very end yeah so great and the it and I
think if you can get on board with a
different style you can enjoy it because
the because even at the very beginning
when it they had actually that actual
credits at the beginning of this and
instantaneously that was something where
I was like okay this is now this is now
a movie a movie yeah yeah because
they're they're cutting to credits
whereas before they didn't have if my
memory serves me correct they didn't
have credits no we just cut right to her
with the firemen yeah yeah and uh yeah
that was great so yeah even like the
Cinematic reveal they treated this one a
lot more cinematically now in terms of
just now taking it after the adjustment
and and uh after adjusting to what the
style is and enjoying that and the
visceral thrills
what did you think overall about the
story and and the characters and stuff I
liked it I didn't like how Lara or Lara
uh kept being like we don't understand
like I was like make these people
smarter like he said it once we all get
it the audience is probably thinking the
same thing like he just told you the
thing that annoyed me a little bit where
I was like why is he like right from the
top I in my brain I thought okay they
probably have a little bit bigger of a
budget and also are there more producers
involved right now that went we trust
what you did with the first one I got a
note we need one guy who's like steaming
off really mad right at the top and then
he loses it and that's what gets us into
this next part of it like in my brain I
thought that that it was like kind of a
bad note like that you can have an
upstairs team that's like but I want
this and I have the money and you're
like okay because that felt off to me
from from the beginning that he was just
like jealous and what do you mean and I
don't understand like you were like what
did you take man did you take like a
bunch of Addie before we got here that
was the only part that threw me off the
rest of it I I did uh really enjoy like
the answers like you said that we
finally found out that it's possession
and
um that the priest was like this is a
secret mission which made it fun which I
liked
um and uh maybe the only other loophole
that I was like wait why is that
firefighter taking the dad with the
antibiotics actually into the building
like that guy just convinced him like no
but these are Anton and he took them and
he's like I can take these for the
infection maybe he convinced the
firefighter that it would heal any
infection that was the only other
loophole that I was like wait why
because the the first one I didn't see
too many
loopholes I I uh plot holes the plot
holes I'm sorry plot holes is the word I
meant I didn't see too many as there was
a couple in here that I was like wait
why is that even
um in there but overall I really I did
enjoy the adventure and it was kind of
um kind of nice to jump around with the
camera angles like with the kids and
then the cops and then uh the regular
camera angle the original one yeah yeah
yeah I I didn't like the characters
anywhere near as much
um yeah like not even remotely close
right and you can't help but especially
for a movie that takes place like
seconds later apparently if you take if
you're watching a movie that takes place
seconds later I think it opens the door
up to compare uh in that regard where
and that one you know like they had more
of a build up to it so before everything
got chaotic but in this one it may it
makes sense to me that you don't get to
spend as much time with the characters
because you're throwing them right into
the Chaos versus a chaos eventually
happening where you get accustomed to
people so you can get invested in them
before [__] starts really hitting the
fan you're like you're the you're the
[__] storm like right away so that made
sense
um why why you couldn't the kids didn't
they were frustrating they were
genuinely frustrating yeah like I like
the presence of the priest I thought he
he had that cool ominous thing about him
like no one here delivered that effect
even though I know they're going for
more of a cinematic approach no one here
to deliver that effect where I was like
like this is not to say that their
acting was bad I wouldn't say anyone's
activist about that everyone was really
committed and gave a strong performance
at the same time the movie never gave me
that feeling of I feel like I'm just
watching real people I still felt like I
was watching actors the whole time
versus the last one even that happened
with like the Angela character too
obviously where she went from you just
feel like a real person to to okay now
you're a performer yeah yes but that's
probably has something to do with the
way the movie's captured to like I'm
sure that factors in to it I wouldn't
say that it falls on the actor solely I
think it's because of the
the way they they switch their genre
around I wasn't sure if the camera guy
in the first one they had a relationship
right this one they we didn't really we
didn't have that no this is just an
immediate situation and it's like levels
and and a bunch of answers with
especially with the religion yeah
because I like the open-endedness of the
first one where you're like it could be
religion or it could be it could be like
a virus yeah and then the first like
five minutes were like oh it's religion
yeah right away they just completely
answer it but the evolution of the um of
the you know like they actually get to
speak and then but yeah they I like how
they they're trying to fuse it though
because I don't know what she's
transferring there at the very end of
the move transferring
She carries it within her the source of
the infection the Satan juice
there's a word for that
um transfer or wait no like the actual
thing that she's transferring uh I've
seen in another like Supernatural I
think it's actually in the show
Supernatural and it's like in other
horror movies too there's a you guys
tell me I'm just gonna call it Satan
juice Satan juice yeah Satan Satan
caterpillar that's what it was
yeah it was disgusting I feel like do
you think that if they started the movie
with where we see the priest and the
SWAT team and maybe some firefighters
like whatever that we kind of look into
their lives for a moment like a moment
before they arrive onto the set to see
like what their lives are like that it
would have made it a little bit like the
original like let's pray let's let's
just say the priest that we saw him get
into saying I'm gonna have to go in and
it has to be a secret mission and how do
I make it happen that we would have
I don't know that maybe we would have
like cared a little bit more that it
would have set it up or would that have
like do you know what I mean yeah
because I didn't I guess we didn't
really get a definitive main lead
character right I'm like this is the
head of the cops or is it the priest
yeah right and and then they wanted to
save it for the reveal of uh like oh
that's really a priest like uh
subverting expectations that it's not
just some medical guy from the last one
this is a priest undercover yeah which
was a good which which did hit yeah I'm
not sure what would have
um alleviated that I just feel like like
you said the thulees like the cop and
the priest that if we had a moment where
I guess with maybe the priest prior to
him going in there without revealing his
priest why is he going in here's the
story and
oh crap here we go and then we get a
point of view of the SWAT I don't know
like I just you know when you have a
little bit of juice on somebody or
someone up front before the action
happens it tends to make you care a
little bit more we didn't we never
really got that which would have I think
would have helped
um because there wasn't anything within
the interactions that made me and feel
endeared to anyone right or feel
connected to anyone and the first one
that's all over yeah yeah
um and then in this and then even with
and the kids too we're just like
bickering annoying little Rebels so I I
didn't and I'm like I'm not just gonna
like them because they're kids I'm like
now you're you're movie character kids
to me you're you're frustrated and I and
I hope that one kid dies I found myself
going oh this kid does it's really
frustrating to be around is that one
girl that one teenage girl just like
lock somewhere she just well yeah she
did they just locked her I saw her legs
go into a room I thought they were in a
locker in there with her brother but
then they ended up tying him up and
different rooms so she's just still
she's burned up I think I'd burn her up
yeah yep but then this also opens the
door and I don't think she got bit so
she's just like a uh she actually was
probably the solo Survivor besides yeah
but that was human did she ordered
though Angela demon possessed Angela
ordered
uh
the
the the them to burn the building right
that's what I meant I meant they're
burning the they did actually burn one
person who was like a human being right
right yeah and not like possessed
because I was like oh she wasn't fit
she's using that bathroom burning and
she was the only one that was like we
shouldn't do this guys I don't want to
go in on the sex doll and this is a dumb
idea and then she gets burned alive and
she had to be the one to kill like the
firefighter and the guy
she just suffered that poor teenage girl
just suffered yep but I did I think
overall though what they wanted to do
was mess around with the filmmaking and
I liked what they did there I I enjoyed
I enjoyed the stylistic touches the
cutting around uh even though it makes
it a little less believable like because
it's because you're watching like
someone
with the found footage you're going
someone that theoretically the idea is
someone found the footage and then
edited together so someone found the
footage decided to you know edit this
together and then let's go back show the
kids now watch a time lapse over yeah
and then how did Angela survive now
let's show that first so now I'm like
who's the one who edited this because my
my head's doing like who edit over as
the first one felt like some government
document thing that they found yeah so
it had that sense of believability
whereas here you're like nah this is
just filmmakers but there were some cool
things there like everything with a
little
evil kids was always really creepy and
scary and just really frenetic that was
awesome yeah I like the uh I even like
the M when she when she does shoot her
uh was it was really neat of the night
vision mode where they have the little
girl possessed now that's cool they
brought that actress back and the little
girls possessed yeah
I I wasn't sure if I was gonna like the
whole possession thing because they went
like full possession here yeah
um but I think I'm so used to American
[__] being like zombie viruses that I'm
I'm actually down for like a possession
thing yeah I like that it was it's
Satan's stuff because the voice can can
change and like uh I guess it just gives
it a little more uh juice when we see
the room with all of the the writings of
like the history of it that you're like
dang this girl's been around for she
looked 99
million years old and she started at 11.
so it's a long time for this like
possession to be there which is very
interesting versus like Zombie Thing
tends to be a lot faster this had more
time to cook I guess for the story true
true so now that was like the next so
because there's like four of them and
they said Rec 4 is called apocalypse so
I guess it succeeds and then this
spreads everywhere why did REC 3 the the
poster of it look like she was in a
wedding dress did I miss is she did I'm
like imagine that I think REC 3 does
take place at a at a wedding but it's
not our girl I don't know if it's our
girl
is that our girl this looks like a very
different person it does look like a
different person uh yeah it's just a
completely separate couple okay got it
uh past two hours
no no it's 81 minutes
we're like a two hours yeah I don't know
I don't know but yeah I I have no idea I
don't know if people like Rec 3. well
it's only got three stars
so maybe not let's do a wreck four got
all right
apocalypse that's almost five damn
that's high holy junk and it's okay
really that's a big jump
like I don't think Rec one had that many
wait a minute there's two wrecked three
options here no they're both three stars
okay
wow that's really hot well let's what
one let's do one comparison here okay
Rec one though has 2.4k votes has three
and a half right
oh oh I see the number of votes right
yeah yeah and then Rec four is what is
it like six 244 people though okay so
okay those are just the hardcore people
who watch the red franchise and they
love it and they're like plead it yeah
let's get it going they're the ones who
watch the abysmal wreck three and we're
like I'm still gonna watch Wreck four
yeah all righty well I don't know I I
like that they did some World building
that was fun that was a lot of fun I had
fun with that one good times uh ladies
and gentlemen what did you think about
wreck two do you like it do you prefer
it more than the first one leave your
thoughts down below be sure to subscribe
go ahead leave a like but let's send
this with a patron of the day shout out
Gabriel now Gabriel he wants me to
comment to us about how you know he
doesn't believe in God and we were
constantly doing like Archangel Gabriel
shout outs so now we're gonna do demonic
possession shout outs today we're going
on the complete opposite side Gabriel
Gabriel if there's anyone here at the
patreon who I would love to possess it
would be you you know what my first
order of business would be as a newly
and indoctrinated demon and then now I'm
possessing you
I would make you a believer in God
I feel like that would be
I would I would be looking for you man
I'd be helping you because for me as a
demon to possess you to exist that would
mean that there has to be a God as well
and so by me possessing you boom saved
your life yeah which would then get me
fired from the Demon World and I would
probably just be lost and trapped in a
endless void or whatever Purgatory they
would just banish me to Purgatory yeah I
guess
back up to the Purgatory like you're out
of hell you're repurgatory it's not as
painful here forever but it's a
punishment I don't
know it's just neutral ground it's
really boring there versus like hell
there's like fire and fury and metal
music and then there's like heaven it's
like
and then Purgatory just
yeah that's probably the worst
experience thank you so much but Gabriel
I would be making sure you are uh gonna
be going to heaven so
I guess your ultimate punishment would
be I convert you into becoming a
believer
yeah
wow he's done it he's become a good
person and started converting people
like a good Mormon boy
that's that's what they do right they go
not door to door and they convert them
that's what the Mormon boys do and the
khakis and the
is that Mormons Church of Jesus Christ
the Latter-Day Saints isn't it the same
thing well some some people who are
Church Jesus Christ Latter-Day Saints
get offended and when you call them
that's Jehovah's Witness dude there it's
all of them see they all do it that's
why we're confused they all knock on the
door with the book and they say follow
the book it's one thing to watch a
religious horror movie it's another
thing to do religious comedies here
[Laughter]
well we've done it praise be to God
Gabriel and also with you